all eyes on london as the city braces
itself for an historic goodbye to the
queen welcome everyone to entertainment
tonight kevin frazier in london with the
latest and kev keep calm and carry on is
taking on a whole new meaning and
nichelle the folks behind me are the
epitome of that statement most of these
people got in the queue or the line
early this morning the hope is that they
will get to see the queen's coffin
sometime before midnight and it is
everyday people and even famous faces
that are lining up like soccer superstar
david beckham
[Music]
i thought by coming at 2 am it was going
to be a little bit quieter i was wrong i
grew up in a household
a royalist so i'm here
on their behalf and on behalf of my
family
an emotional beckham in black today
removed his cap inside westminster hall
to honor her majesty who united him in
2003. it's a sad day but it's a day for
us to to remember you know the
incredible legacy that she's left
the soccer superstar said he waited more
than 12 hours in the line which by the
way stretches more than five and a half
miles it got so long and so congested
that they closed it down this morning
for six hours and according to some
estimates if you are at the back of that
line you could wait up to 24 hours
that's king charles giving a speech in
welsh earlier today he visited wales
with camilla and notably appeared to
bring his own pen to sign the visitors
book after this week's viral pen snafu
and it was actually quote at the king's
request that harry be allowed to wear
his military uniform at tomorrow night's
vigil it will take place right behind us
in westminster hall
harry william and the other six
grandchildren will all stand in silence
for 15 minutes to honor their
grandmother e.t has learned that spouses
will not be in attendance that includes
kate and megan
but tonight it was her majesty's
children who stood in vigil
and have you been a part of this
celebration
earlier will and kate met army personnel
deployed to help with the massive state
funeral there was a full dress rehearsal
last night and there will be another
tonight now heathrow has actually
canceled 100 flights that were set to
take off during the funeral and that is
so there will not be any plane noise
during the procession as for the guest
list well we know royal fan tom cruise
has a home in london he attended the
royal jubilee william and kate also
attended the top gun maverick premiere
we saw the crowns clear foyer at
heathrow yesterday and then there's all
the celebs the queen has knighted
including elton john my deepest
condolences to the family e.t was with
elton's husband david furnish both
attended princess diana's funeral at
westminster where elton famously played
the 75 year old is currently on tour
he'll be in north carolina on sunday but
e.t has learned he has monday open we
celebrate our life tonight with music
okay
[Music]